no longer in office but still hitting
the headlines for all the wrong reasons
the former prime minister and the party
Gate scandal
overshadowing Rishi sunak's early
achievements on brexit and he might as
well get used to it with the latest
investigation set to escalate over the
coming weeks and revealing new evidence
that could lead to Boris Johnson being
kicked out of parliament altogether
future depends on whether he knowingly
misled MPS when he was confronted in the
House of Commons all guidance was
followed completely during number 10. I
have been repeatedly assured that the
rules
whatever happened the guidance was
followed and the rules were followed at
all times
it's parliament's privileges committee
that will decide whether those denials
were genuine but even as more evidence
emerges there are still those that are
loyal to the former prime minister Boris
Johnson was a Prime Minister elected by
the overwhelming majority of the country
80 seat majority and
um the way his reputation has been
besmirched the way uh this has happened
I think is evidence of not a serious
country
labor Keen to capitalize on the latest
episode of The partygate Saga say it's
Rishi sunak who is ultimately
responsible for whether his predecessor
is punished will he be clear actually
that if Boris Johnson has been found to
have lied repeatedly to Parliament to
have misled Parliament repeatedly that
actually Boris Johnson's career should
be over
Rishi sunak promised a new start when he
took over at number 10 but the man that
came before him and the illegal parties
that went on in the building behind me
are still casting a very long Shadow
here and whilst the Prime Minister and
many of his MPS would like to leave it
all in the past this latest
investigation is forcing them to face it
all over again
in the end though it could be Boris
Johnson's constituency that decides his
future by way of a recall petition if
enough of them sign it that will trigger
a by-election he didn't in my opinion
really you know hold his hands up and
really say you know
I messed up yeah he made mistakes but
then everybody makes mistakes you know
if anyone acts like that in a position
of power I think they should step down
back at number 10 things may have
changed since the party gate days but
the Fallout is still being felt Liz
Bates Sky News Westminster